c'est un spectacle impressionnant des
vagues s'écrase sur cette plage de
volcom houdan nord-est du
nouveau-brunswick le vent parfois
violent donne vie aux drapeaux sous
l'oeil des résidents du coin venus
admirer les forces de la nature
un petit groupe s'approche de l'eau
planche sous le bras vêtus de
combinaisons isothermiques il s'apprête
à défier les vagues
les bateaux ne sont même pas en mer et
pourtant ça n'arrête pas les membres
d'haqqani seule balle mauvais temps pour
nous on sait le meilleur temps donc
lorsqu'il ya des grosses vagues qui
vient cascades et en paix comme des gros
hors des camps n'a peur enfin tenter le
quai les meilleures vagues on arrive
françois ciation et présidents d'acca
des surfeurs groupe de passionnés de six
ports meetic qui allie planches le vent
et les émotions fortes
le but c'est de rassembler les gens qui
fait d'effort nautiques dans la région
d'ici parce que c'est des sports qu'on
pense qui est très court puis très
plaisant à faire on a un stock et pour
faire ce sport là la péninsule acadienne
et apparaît du livre et sur le feu vous
diront même que l'endroit est un trésor
caché pour seulement depuis quelques
années mais depuis très longtemps on a
une richesse dans la péninsule acadienne
ici en surf kitesurf windsurf ce genre
de sport dont la création est un des
vétérans de kate issue
il a voyagé beaucoup avec sa planche à
voile pour lui la région est sous-estimé
pour se rendre compte que certaines
endroits qui étaient publicité aux
buttes dans les grands magazines ont été
aussi bons qu'ils sont comme on est en
en iso on se dit mais il faut le dire à
quelqu'un faut dire à quelqu'un
évidemment il ya quelques endroits sont
exceptionnelles à wailly australie
effigie mais si tu vois dans toutes les
autres catégories jeux sont en bois de
toi on est là dedans on a un 8 sur 10 un
autre des objectifs de cadix heures
c'est d'attirer et de garder les jeunes
dans la péninsule
une façon de démontrer qu'on peut avoir
du plaisir ici car le potentiel est là
je suis quand même surpris à toutes ces
années comme à ce que les opposants
demandent qu'on que je pensais qui en
ferait tellement la région est belle
c'est qu'à première vue le surfeur est
plus accessible
lors de notre passage par exemple les
vagues ne collaborent pas toujours le
sport demande de la patience il faut
travailler pendant plusieurs minutes
pour trouver la vague parfaite pour
quinze ou vingt secondes d'extase admin
hello c'est pas facile pour lui
première fois mais ça s'apprend très
bien donc ça dépend des conditions et
des conditions qui puissent servir des
conditions plus difficiles
lui-même passionné de planche et autres
actes et françois situation rappelle
toute la satisfaction d'apprendre à
maîtriser un appareil en utilisant les
forces de nature sa première envolée
aujourd'hui n'est pas évident d'aborder
dans l'honneur et quand il fait beau le
plaisir est inégalée ici on oublie la
pandémie et les soucis ici françois
leblanc radio canada havel comeau